here's what would happen if you stopped  sweating if all your sweat glands  stopped functioning you wouldn't sweat  without a way for your body to get rid  of excess heat even the simplest  activities like standing walking or  eating dinner would cause your body  temperature to increase your skin would  start to feel dry and hot your ears  would turn red you'd start to feel  lethargic and irritated you'd suffered  from heat exhaustion and your heart rate  would increase the only solution at this  point would be to get to the coolest  place you can if you weren't able to  cool down you'd get heat stroke at  temperatures higher than 39 degrees your  blood brain barrier would break down  that means unwanted particles and  bacteria would start to build up in the  brain leading to inflammation eventually  you could lose Consciousness there's a  good chance you'd have permanent brain  damage or worse you could die so